on va voir un piège d'ouverture qui peut
vous permettre de mater en seulement 7
coups avec les Noirs ça marche
généralement super bien jusqu'à 1200
1400 € cheesecom si votre adversaire
connais pas et en plus c'est sur
l'ouverture la plus jouée par les Blancs
l'italienne bonjour on commence par E4
E5 car il y a trois qui est C6 le Fou
vient en C4 et là on joue cavalier
Descartes on appelle ça le Gambie
Blackburn parce qu'on offre le pion E5
en peinture qui a l'air très tentant
puisque les blancs attaquent derrière F7
par deux fois sauf que c'est une faute
et là on contre par dame G5 double
attaque sur G2 et le cavalier si les
blancs sont gourmand par cahier pro M7
la fourchette alors on punit sur le
champ dame prend G2 la tour d'oie bouger
dame prend le 4 échec le fou obligé de
reculer pour couvrir et là c'est Matt
allez tout fait avec le cavalier en
seulement 7 coups petite astuce si
jamais au passage les blancs prennent en
F7 avec le fou alors on bouge juste le
roi là les blancs vont devoir défendre
ce pion en Rocan et derrière on encaisse
le cavalier et on est également gagnant
Margaret